progrès lent mais significatif la
contre-offensive ukrainienne continue
l'armée de Kiev repousse petit à petit
les troupes russes vers l'est du pays
malgré le retrait des soldats de Moscou
ceux qui vivent près de la ligne de
front reste en danger dans la ville de
nicolaeka les Russes ont frappé mercredi
cette école qui servait d'abris un
bombardement dans lequel on périt des
civils
personne ne sait ce qu'il faut faire
personne ne sait à quoi s'attendre tout
ce qui arrive est juste tellement triste
et dangereux
qu'est-ce que nous avons fait à Dieu ici
dans l'est de l'Ukraine
l'un des objectifs clés de Kiev et
d'encercler la ville de Limone elle est
stratégique dans la provisionnement du
don-basse de son côté le Kremlin affirme
qu'une offensive ukrainienne a échoué
mercredi et que 70 soldats ukrainiens
ont été tués la ville est sous
occupation russe depuis mai dernier Kiev
affirme que sa reconquête constituerait
une importante victoire